anthem is something entirely new from Y
aware and so we wanted to promote it in
a way that we've never done before
[Music]
corn maze
sure we could have written something in
the sky on a billboard that covered the
side of a building but you know what's
bigger than a building a feel
[Music]
John really had his heart set on corn I
mean what better way to show the growth
of a new game than through corn which
also grows so we asked Edmonton corn
maze if he could buy their design and
they said sure we've been doing this for
17 years this is their seventeenth year
and every year we try and make it
something cool and fun for people to
walk through when I was approached to
create the design for this maze I
thought this this is the biggest
challenge of my artistic career never
before had I worked with a medium as
temperamental this is challenging as
corn he was asking all sorts of
questions about color schemes and
half-tones and I said Neil its corn it
took weeks of effort but ultimately this
this is the greatest thing I have ever
done with this maze it was fairly usual
we just follow the lines in front of us
and cut
and hope that it all grows yeah we start
with an empty field and we plant the
whole field in rows going your south and
east west and then we
Taylor and chillip to pass
we couldn't be happy with how it all
turned out I mean it's a 50-foot exosuit
so what's it been like working with fire
to pull this off Joe we did like say
it's been working with Bioware has been
fun yeah yeah that works
working with Bioware has been really
good it's been lots of fun